bienvenue dans le débat de France 24 aux
États-Unis on vote dans exactement une
semaine pour les élections de mi-mandat
ces élections elles servent à renouveler
l'ensemble des 435 sièges de la Chambre
des Représentants et un tiers du Sénat
et à cette occasion et bien nombreux
États compter et villes organisent aussi
des scrutins cette échéance deux ans
après la présidentielle et bien souvent
périlleuse pour le président en place et
d'ailleurs plus la date du 8 novembre
approche et plus les indicateurs Virton
rouge la couleur du parti républicain
alors la victoire est-elle acquise pour
les républicains mardi prochain en quoi
ces élections vont être déterminantes
pour la suite du mandat de Joe Biden
mais aussi pour l'avenir politique de
Donald Trump son prédécesseur après une
campagne marquée par des violences
politiques ces élections sont elles un
test pour la démocratie américaine on va
en débattre avec nos invités ce soir
amnesine à mes côtés professeur émérite
à Paris Nanterre auteur de les
États-Unis et la démocratie aux éditions
l'Harmattan indéine bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous Gérald Olivier à vos côtés
chercheurs associés à l'IPSE auteur de
sur la route de la Maison Blanche
également journaliste franco-américain
Gérald Olivier bonsoir et puis en face
de vous James Cohen porte-parole du
démocrate brode France professeur
d'études américaines à l'université
Paris 3 Sorbonne Nouvelle bonsoir on va
d'abord si vous le voulez bien partir à
Washington retrouver Matthieu mabande
notre correspondant pour faire un point
sur la situation aux États-Unis dans le
pays justement à une semaine tout juste
avant ces élections Matthieu bonsoir
les récents sondages donne une large
victoire des républicains à la Chambre
des représentants des républicains qui
gagnent du terrain de jour en jour
vous voyez claire je vous demande pardon
par avance je vais être un petit peu
long puisque la situation générale ici
atteint un tel niveau de complexité
qu'il faut bien expliquer un peu je
commencerai par souligner ce qui se
dessine désormais comme le paradoxe de
cette élection nous avons d'un côté une
population américaine qui quand on l'a
consulté à grands coups d'études et de
sondages exprime souvent parfois avec
violence sont rejet des appareils
politiques américains purement et
simplement la classe polémique
américaine dans son ensemble à basculer
ces derniers mois et disons-le
progressivement ces dernières années
dans un état d'impopularité qui va qui
va des records désormais mais là où il y
a un paradoxe c'est que pour exprimer ce
mécontentement les électeurs américains
se préparent non pas à bouder les urnes
comme le ferait les Français par exemple
mais au contraire à battre un record de
participation pour ces élections dans
une semaine une récente étude révèle que
71% des Américains sont hostiles à un
second le mandat de Joe Biden et pas
seulement pour son âge on croyait avoir
atteint une forme de paroxysme dans la
polarisation de ce pays en 2016 avec
l'élection Donald Trump mais
concrètement six ans après cette épisode
qui avait on s'en souvient sidéré le
monde nous sommes obligés de constater
que la situation générale à globalement
empiré et cette campagne des miteur ne
fait que confirmer cette tendance durant
quatre ans nous étions habitués au
discours qu'on peut qualifier
d'outrancier de Donald Trump à qui
beaucoup d'observateurs attributs de
manière un peu hâtive peut-être
l'intégralité de la responsabilité de
cette polarisation mais début septembre
quand Joe Biden s'est rendu à
Philadelphie en Pennsylvanie un état clé
le président en exercice n'a pas hésité
à désigner les électeurs républicains
comme des ennemis de la démocratie
américaine à peine a-t-il épargner ce
petit groupe de républicains hostile à
Donald Trump qui concrètement
aujourd'hui ne représente plus que même
dans ce pays le durcissement du discours
démocrate n'a rien arrangé donc à la
polarisation évidemment et ce
durcissement se décline de l'échelon
fédéral jusqu'à l'échelon du comté et
même du district dans certains spots de
campagne républicains on peut voir des
candidats tirés à la mitrailleuse ou au
fusil d'assaut au moment où la moitié
des femmes de ce pays se sont vus
confisquer purement et simplement leurs
droits à disposer de leur corps et pas
par n'importe quelle institution par la
Cour suprême des États-Unis la violence
en politique dont on croyait avoir vu
l'expression ultime et que vous évoquiez
à l'instant avec l'attaque du Capitole
le 6 janvier 2020 se manifeste tous les
jours ici en réalité sous une forme ou
sous une autre il y a quelques jours la
résidence privée de Nancy Pelosi vous
l'avez suivi on a largement développé
sur France 24 à littéralement été
attaquée par un théoricien du complot
jusqu'à frapper le mari de la speaker de
la Chambre des Représentants avec un
marteau comprenons-nous bien c'est bien
dans ce contexte parce que les
Américains vont se rendre aux urnes dans
une semaine côté la républicain il y a
bien quelques figures qui émergent mais
qui ne présage finalement pas tellement
d'apaisement avec Ron De Santis le
gouverneur de Floride ou le sénateur
Marco Rubio pour ne citer que lui aussi
Marco Rubio originaire de Floride mais
la pression sera également à son comble
et vous l'avez évoqué brièvement en
Pennsylvanie et en Géorgie cet état-clé
qui annonce effectivement de faire
basculer le Sénat côté républicain en
Pennsylvanie les débats qui opposent le
démocrate John feterman et Memet Oz sont
globalement à l'image du climat national
et enfin je prendrai un dernier exemple
avec le Rayo et la démocrate marsicacher
élu pourtant depuis 1983 mais dont le
fauteuil est menacé par le républicain
madjevski qui se présente comme un
ancien militaire mais qui semble s'être
inventé une bonne partie de ces états de
service je terminerai en rappelant
de ce scrutin si Joe Biden perd sa
majorité à la Chambre de représentants
et au Sénat on peut considérer que
techniquement son mandat s'arrête là en
tout cas que c'est la fin de sa capacité
à réformer ce pays qui en a tant besoin
pourtant une situation qui n'est pas
exceptionnelle aux États-Unis mais qui
dans le contexte international autant
économique que militaire naugure
vraiment rien de bon merci beaucoup
Matthieu Mabin en direct de Washington
voilà pour le tableau général moi
j'aimerais d'abord qu'on commence sur
les thèmes de cette campagne essayer de
comprendre pourquoi les républicains
aujourd'hui sont en tête c'est notamment
James Cohen à cause de l'économie les
démocrates n'ont pas su se saisir de ces
sujets aujourd'hui les républicains ils
parlent beaucoup inflation notamment
taux d'intérêt et c'est le sujet qui
intéresse aujourd'hui les électeurs
américains
le cadre est déjà donné n'est ce pas on
a déjà donné des démocrateurs mais je
suis pas d'accord je pense que ce n'est
pas du tout dit le Sénat peut être sauvé
et la chambre aussi
on sait ce que donne les sondages on
sait ce que disent les sondages on sait
ce que disent à peu près tous les
commentateurs mais je me souviens aussi
des sondages de 2016 qui donnaient le
weekend gagnante jusqu'à la dernière
seconde moi je ne crois plus au sein
d'âge je pense que il faut voir qui se
mobilise et combien ils seront et elles
seront le jour le 8 novembre rendez-vous
donc le 9 pour parler des résultats
[Musique]
quelque chose parce qu'il a été dit
parce que reprocher au malheureux
président Biden de polariser le débat
alors qu'il s'est contenté enfin de
réagir à un monde médiatique de
l'extrême droite avec ces espèces de
bulles cognitives ou à cause de la
dictature du Premier Amendement tous ces
gens-là peuvent mentir dire les pires
horreurs inciter à la violence sans
qu'on puisse sanctionner parce que la
Cour suprême dans sa grande sagesse a
dit que un danger imminent c'était la
liberté d'expression donc ce qu'a fait
le président a Philadelphie c'est
simplement finalement prendre acte qu'on
ne pouvait plus traiter de la même façon
les démocrates et les républicains et
que pour les médias c'est la même chose
les médias ont eu du mal ils continuent
ils ont beaucoup critiqué bydad au début
en se disant ah on a beaucoup critiqué
Trump faut qu'on critique Biden mais
c'est pas la même chose il y a un parti
qui joue dans les règles du jeu et il y
a un autre qui veut renverser les règles
du jeu renverser le système démocratique
donc je pense que notre rôle ici c'est
de montrer un petit peu on ne sait pas
ce qui va se passer moi je suis pas sûr
que les démocrates gardent la chambre
mais j'ai un petit espoir pour le Sénat
parce que le Sénat c'est aussi là que
Biden peut obtenir la confirmation des
juges fédéraux et Messieurs Trump a
obtenu la confirmation 253 et c'est pour
ça qu'on a tout un tas de pure produit
de la faible non seulement la Cour
suprême mais dans les juridictions
fédérales donc quelque part espérons que
au moins le Sénat sera sauvé à la
chambre sommeil il va y avoir le
chantage à la dette le chantage au
plafond de la dette au budget des
enquêtes surtout le fils byden le
méchant ministre de la Justice pour bien
faire peut-être deux ou trois
propositions dit pitchment le chaos le
plus total rien certain qui dit c'est
peut-être une bonne affaire pour les
démocrates de perdre la chambre parce
que les Américains vont peut-être enfin
avoir que les républicains n'ont pas de
programme et que quand ils sont au
pouvoir c'est bon
ce que je suis pas du tout d'accord
sur les thèmes aussi de la de la
campagne avant de parler des de la
démocratie la base de la démocratie
c'est de respecter les idées des autres
y compris quand elle vous déplaisent ce
que Monsieur Biden a fait le 1er
septembre lors de son discours à
Philadelphie c'est de traiter de
terroristes ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec lui et qui soutiennent
Donald Trump c'est quand même un petit
peu fort dans le pays qui se prétend la
première démocratie au monde maintenant
pour répondre à votre question où il y a
deux que il y a deux deux questions qui
ont mobilisé des Américains d'ailleurs
pas simplement pour la campagne mais
depuis le 1er janvier 2021 la première
c'est l'inflation la seconde c'est une
criminalité rampante d'accord les
démocrates pendant la campagne n'en
parlait que de deux choses l'avortement
et la journée du 6 janvier et
manifestement l'électorat ne répond pas
parce que ce ne sont pas là ces
préoccupations du quotidien vous allez
occupe les Américains c'est de mettre de
l'essence dans leur voiture pour aller
au travail ce qui préoccupe les
Américains c'est d'envoyer leurs enfants
à l'école et de faire en sorte qu'ils y
apprennent des choses qui va de la peine
d'être apprises et qu'ils y aillent de
manière safe en toute sécurité que
eux-mêmes puissent sortir le soir en
toute sécurité vous savez que depuis que
Biden est président les ventes d'armes
ont continué d'exploser aux États-Unis
vous savez quel est le segment de la
société qui aujourd'hui achète le plus
d'armes qui sont les femmes qui sont les
femmes ce sont les femmes qui achètent
des pistolets pour se défendre parce
qu'elles ont peur de se faire agresser
dans la rue ça c'est les États-Unis de
Joe Biden donc là on va avoir une
élection avec des é et on va compter les
votes de manière aussi on va dire fiable
que l'on peut souhaiter que ça se soit
et on verra le résultat c'est la
démocratie qui parlera James Cohen il
aurait dû parler davantage d'économies
Joe Biden plutôt que de parler de
l'avortement du droit des minorités dans
cette campagne la situation n'est
clairement pas facile il y a un taux
d'inflation qui tourne autour de 8% et
de là à dire que la totalité de cette
inflation est due à la gestion de Jobin
j'entends ça tout le temps dans la
bouche des républicains le long large du
pays mais c'est très schématique c'est
c'est un peu n'importe quoi on peut pas
reprocher toute l'inflation ou même une
grande partie de cette inflation à des
facteurs nationaux il y a des facteurs
internationaux systémiques qui jouent
par ailleurs je pense qu'il y a aussi
des entreprises privées qui pouvaient
être un peu plus dans leur
recherche des profits mais on en parle
peu mais si on désigne regarder les
sondages quand on regarde les sondages
pardon les statistiques on constate que
la criminalité violente les meurtres des
crus des crus depuis les années 80 ce
qui a un peu cru pendant le covid je
pense pas qu'on puisse incriminer Joe
Biden c'est la petite criminalité les
vols et Larsa peut-être les arrachages
de sac alors peut-être certaines femmes
soumises à cette propagande ce
martèlement par les républicains et
l'impossibilité de dire la vérité on
peut pour leur sécurité et effectivement
comme on leur explique avoir un revolver
c'est bien alors que généralement c'est
ça qui crée le chaos elle s'achète un
petit revolver c'est le gamin qui va se
tuer avec ou qui va tuer sa maman avec
mais ça c'est le résultat ce lavage de
cerveau c'est très intéressant ce que
dit Madame parce que c'est exactement ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis il y a eu un
débat la semaine dernière entre les deux
candidats pour être gouverneur de New
York madame
occulte qui est la gouver la gouverneur
actuelle qui n'a pas été élu parce
qu'elle a remplacé Andrew il y a un an
et Monsieur Zeldin qui est son
challenger New York c'est un état
démocrate et aujourd'hui madame aucune
est menacé ne donne pas être élu c'est à
dire de perdre et que New York bascule
dans le corps républicain or la question
de la criminalité a été soulevée et
Madame aucune a fait exactement la même
réflexion que Madame ici c'est à dire
non non c'est faux de dire que ça
augmente ça n'augmente pas c'est de la
propagande c'est une sensation c'est pas
une sensation pour les Américains et la
preuve c'est qu'à la suite de ce débat
madame aucune a été extrêmement critiqué
y compris chez les démocrates pour son
insensibilité à un problème qui touche
les électeurs et l'un des problèmes du
Parti démocrate dans cette campagne
électorale c'est un déni de réalité et
une déconnexion totale avec lectorat et
c'est pour ça que les républicains
enlevant en poupe parce que eux
répondent à de vraies aspirations et que
les électeurs ont en face d'eux des gens
qui répondent à leurs attentes vous avez
des organisé
de la part du Parti démocrate non j'ai
pas du tout je crois que j'ai senti un
petit peu de déni là à propos de
l'avortement de de de droit des femmes à
déni du tout j'aimerais justement
attendez l'avortement en question la
décision de la décision de la Cour
suprême la décision de la Cour suprême a
rendu aux États une responsabilité qui
avait été la leur de 1776 à 1973 il a
pas du tout interdit l'avortement ça
c'est faux l'avortement est toujours
autorisé dans tous les États américains
mais il savait pas dire qu'il n'est pas
garanti du tout il est toujours protégé
dans 15 États j'aimerais justement tous
les jours
Texas 6 semaines en tant que femme je
peux vous dire à six semaines on sait
pas qu'on est enceinte et ben justement
on va on va regarder un reportage sur ça
après la décision en juin dernier de la
Cour suprême de ne plus garantir
justement donc ce droit à l'avortement
au niveau fédéral à l'approche du
scrutin notre correspondante aux
Etats-Unis Fanny Allard s'est rendu dans
Louise cancin ou avorter n'est plus
possible justement depuis la révocation
de cette arrêt rovy Wade on va regarder
son reportage et puis on va continuer à
en parler après
Samoa est à 23 ans tombé enceinte par
accident au mois de mai elle devait
avorter à 230 km d'ici le jour où la
Cour suprême des États-Unis a révoqué la
révis
devait m'emmener en voiture elle est
arrivée chez moi tout était prêt et j'ai
reçu une notification sur mon téléphone
qui disait que l'arrêt roviewade était
annulé l'instant d'après je recevais un
coup de fil du planning familial qui me
prévenait qu'il ne pourrait pas me
prendre en charge parce que l'avortement
était devenu illégal j'étais furieuse
pour l'impact de cette décision sur
notre pays et pour son impact sur moi
personnellement
étudiante le jour serveuse la nuit les
jeunes femmes n'aurait pas eu les moyens
d'élever un enfant seul elle a
finalement pu se rendre dans l'état
voisins du Minnesota pour interrompre sa
grossesse
c'était extrêmement dur pour moi mais je
me sens quand même privilégiée parce que
je suis à l'université j'ai un boulot et
une voiture c'était une situation
terrible mais je n'imagine pas ce que ça
doit être quand on a pas les moyens et
je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui parmi tous
les problèmes auxquels s'efface notre
pays le droit des femmes et ceux qui
compte le plus pour moi
le Wisconsin est revenu à l'application
d'une loi de 1849 qui interdit
l'avortement même en cas de viol ou
d'inceste sauf s'il y a danger pour la
vie de la mer pour les défenseurs des
droits reproductifs le seul espoir d'un
retour en arrière et donc de voter le 8
novembre bonjour vous êtes Laura oui
bonjour Laura je m'appelle Joella je
fais partie des militants du planning
familial du Wisconsin nous voulons
savoir comment les membres de la
communauté appréhendent l'annulation de
reviewade il faut savoir qu'il existe
des moyens de restaurer l'avortement
légal je suis inquiète mais savoir que
des gens sont prêts à se battre pour ce
que nous méritons tous ça me donne de
l'espoir face à la situation le planning
familial a lancé une campagne nationale
de 50 millions de dollars pour pousser
la population aux urnes
je crois qu'il est primordial que nous
élions des représentants prêts à se
battre pour restaurer l'accès à
l'avortement à l'échelle législative et
judiciaire pour redonner accès à ce soin
essentiel
partout aux États-Unis les femmes se
mobilisent et s'inscrivent en masse sur
les listes électorales dans le Wisconsin
selon une récente étude les nouvelles
électrices étaient 17% de plus que les
hommes
est-ce que les démocrates peuvent
espérer cette mobilisation des femmes
justement la participation ça va être un
des enjeux pour ces élections de
mi-manda alors la participation elle est
très forte et c'est une surprise parce
que dans beaucoup d'États républicains
les républicains ont adopté des
législations pour rendre le vote plus
difficile ils ont supprimé des jours de
vote anticipée ils ont rendu difficile
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
etc mais si on prend l'exemple de la
Géorgie que qui est surveillée très près
à cause du poste de gouverneur du poste
de sénateur etc on constate que malgré
tous ces obstacles et la Géorgie est
l'une des législations les plus
restrictives les taux sont ahurissants
je veux pas dire de bêtises mais ils
sont beaucoup plus élevés qu'en 2020 ou
déjà ça avait été très élevé donc il y a
de la participation mais il est très
possible que les soit aussi mobilisée
galvanisé que les démocrates donc on ne
sait pas les shifts ne sont pas
suffisamment précis pour qu'on sache
exactement qui se précipitent pour voter
avant la date des élections l'avortement
on a vu que ça jouait un rôle majeur
après la décision qui est tombée le 24
ou le 26 juin et c'est vrai que tout le
mois de juillet les démocrates ont eu le
vent en poupe et il y a eu l'espoir du
côté démocrate ça retombe un peu sur le
mois de septembre et personnellement je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec Jim
je pense que les démocrates ont mis trop
d'eux dans les mêmes paniers quand on
voit les publicités électorales
l'avortement c'est 181 millions
c'est-à-dire trois fois plus que
l'économie or il y a un bilan économique
il y a le relancement
et donc les démocrates aurait peut-être
pu dépenser un peu d'argent en publicité
électorale à défendre notamment un taux
de chômage assez faible en 3,5%. alors
Biden là aussi à changer non seulement
il a incriminé les et pas tous les
républicains mais il est en train de
dire cette élection c'est pas un
référendum pour ou contre moi c'est un
choix entre deux modèles économiques
hein celui des républicains qui ne
bénéficient riche le fameux tricol down
qui se produit jamais l'économie de
l'offre etc etc où on sort dans les
dépenses où il y a pas d'infrastructure
ou les pensées fondre et puisque nous
faisons nous qui est remettre la santé
remettre la phrase structure et faire en
sorte de créer des emplois grâce à la
lutte pour le climat pour la classe
ouvrière et des emplois comme il a dit
des good pain Jobs des emplois qui
paient avec une couverture médicale donc
peut-être que ce que spare Jim est
beaucoup c'est que ce message qui a
commencé simplement il y a une semaine
alors il reste deux semaines et certains
ont déjà voté va pouvoir peut-être
rétablir le trop de 2 millions de
personnes déjà qui sont prononcées dans
les états où le vote anticipé
justement mardi prochain
justement vous évoquiez le climat James
Cohen la question climatique elle a été
un peu absente de cette campagne
nous sommes je pense malgré les
catastrophes les tensions terribles nous
sommes en pleine guerre en Europe sur
les bords de l'Europe et ça affecte
aussi les questions énergétiques il y a
une
recherche
d'indépendance énergétique qui qui fait
que la reconversion qui s'impose
et ralenti et c'est dommage mais dans la
législation que défendaient les
démocrates ces deux dernières années il
y a plein de choses qui vont dans le
sens d'une d'une véritable reconversion
pour sortir des énergies fossiles et
même dans la législation qui a été
adoptée il y avait moins de milliards en
jeu mais il y a quand même un certain
nombre
Gérald Olivier les réagir indirectement
la question du climat a été évoquée à
travers la question de l'énergie c'est à
dire que justement cette transition
énergétique elle faisait partie de la
campagne de 2020 et elle a été imposée
par Joe Biden et démocrate de sang la
Maison Blanche et c'est massivement
rejeté par les lectorats parce que
l'électorat justement veut des voitures
comment qui vous le dit les électeurs
les électeurs qui ne sont pas contents
de payer le litre d'essence enfin le
galon d'essence à 5 dollars alors qu'il
en coûtait moins de deux dans Donald
Trump et ça c'était il y a 18 mois
l'écologie qui cause la hausse du prix
de l'essence c'est le fait que depuis
que Baden est arrivé il a fermé les
gisements il a interdit les permis de
d'exploitation et de production
supprimer le piston pipeline qui devait
acheminer du pétrole jusque dans le
golfe du Mexique du temps de Donald
Trump les États-Unis produisaient plus
d'hydrocarbures qu'ils n'en consommait
aujourd'hui ils sont à moins de 2
millions de barils jour de déficit et ça
c'est ça c'était des politiques qui
existaient avant qui ont été supprimés
par les démocrates et qui ont provoqué
cette crise de l'énergie et cette crise
de l'énergie elle est délibérée pour
justement amener cette fameuse
transition énergétique et bien on va
voir dans une semaine avec les électeurs
comment cette politique va être
sanctionnée parce qu'elle l'est déjà
Donald Trump très présent dans cette
campagne j'aimerais justement qu'on
s'arrête sur le climat de cette campagne
un climat violence
qui l'agression au marteau notre
correspondant Mathieu Mabin l'évoquais
chez le Marine Nancy Pelosi la semaine
dernière on est un exemple exemple du
raidissement du climat politique
outre-Atlantique on va écouter les
réactions de Joe Biden et Barack Obama
justement juste après ces attaques et
puis on va en reparler
c'est ignoble il n'y a aucun endroit en
Amérique où il n'y a pas de violence de
violence politique
il y a trop de haine trop de vitriol
comment pouvons-nous penser qu'un parti
peut parler d'élection volée de covid
qui serait un canular de tout un tas de
mensonges sans affecter les gens qui ne
sont peut-être pas tout à fait
équilibrées
le fondement même de notre démocratie
est actuellement remis en question
les démocrates ne sont pas parfaits je
suis le premier à l'admettre
les politiciens comme nous tous peuvent
faire des erreurs
mais en ce moment à quelques exceptions
près la plupart des républicains et tout
un tas de candidats ne cherchent même
plus à respecter les règles
ils inventent ce qui les arrangent
aujourd'hui la démocratie américaine oui
dans cette numération avec un nombre de
sièges qui est proportionnelle à la
population et par contre le Sénat le
Sénat représente les états avec deux
sièges quel que soit la population de
cet état ce sont les institutions
américaines depuis 1786 sauf que les
républicains font de l'obstruction avec
la majorité c'est plus 50 sièges 50 voix
c'est 60 maintenant mais pour revenir au
violence
James Cohen il y a eu cette attaque du
Marine Nancy Pelosi des élus et des
agents électoraux aussi alertes contre
le regain de violence qu'il est vise
dernièrement à quoi il est dû cette
violence c'est la conséquence de
l'extrême polarisation de la société
américaine conséquence
seulement avec votre correspondant tout
à l'heure je pense que la polarisation
est très élevée mais je pense que le
vecteur fondamental de ce polarisation
c'est le parti républicain sous
l'influence de Trump ça ne vient pas les
démocrates on l'invente côté
républicain toutes sortes de problèmes
polarisants
et on invente des enjeux et on attribue
au démocrates toutes sortes de position
imaginée mais mais la violence du propos
et l'ambiance de soupçon ça vient
clairement d'un côté et pas de l'autre
Gérald Olivier c'est la conséquence de
l'air Trump ce qui est en train de se
passer
élu Trump c'est le résultat des
divisions c'est pas le CEPAL diviseur
lui il a été élu justement parce que
division était là était là avant lui
ensuite la violence politique mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas reconnu
la victoire de Joe Biden avait pas
reconnu la victoire de Trump elle l'a
appelé le président illégitime pendant 4
ans et personne n'y a jamais rien dit à
ce sujet donc c'est exactement la même
chose la violence fonctionne dans les
deux sens malheureusement et
souvenez-vous de certains démocrates
Maxime Waters qui est une représentante
de Los Angeles qui disait à ses
militants il faut aller in the face il
faut aller au contact des républicains
quand ils ont des opinions qui ne vous
plaisent pas je rappelle que monsieur
rampol qui est également sénateur du
Kentucky a été agressé quand il était à
Washington dans un restaurant personne
s'en
résister c'est devenu un drame c'est pas
des fous de républicains qui démocrates
qui sont rentrés l'assassiner c'est pas
trois personnes qui manifestaient c'est
vous qui n'y est la réalité je dis les
démocrates ont un problème de déni de
réalité et là après tout ce que vous
dites vous vous montrez que j'ai raison
à chaque fois on n'a pas encore évoqué
les centaines de candidats républicains
à l'échelle nationale qui ni les
résultats des élections de 2020
et 300 à se présenter et primaire et
voilà et à ne pas reconnaître tout à
fait l'élection
où on est vraiment en danger de voir les
résultats cassés si les républicains
n'aiment pas de résultats il y a eu 60
actions en justice intentées par les
républicains et les 60 ont été déboutés
y compris certaines par la Cour suprême
avec les petits camarades de Monsieur
mais aux États-Unis aussi environ 70%
des électeurs républicains continuent de
croire que l'actuel président Joe Biden
est illégitime c'est ce que révèle
plusieurs sondages mes réseaux sociaux
comment vous expliquer ça que 70%
aujourd'hui des Américains
considèrent Joe Biden comme illégitime
l'élection 2020 a été une élection qui
était exceptionnelle à cause de
l'importance du vote par correspondance
et ce vote par correspondance a créé
deux choses la première c'est une
participation exceptionnelle
deuxièmement c'est un écart de voix
également exceptionnel ensuite on a eu
souvenez-vous en Pennsylvanie dans le
Wisconsin en Géorgie des résultats qui
étaient retardés on ne les connaissait
pas à tous les tous les bulletins
n'étaient pas encore rentrés on a vu en
2020 une situation qui était très très
inhabituelle voire inconnue aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire que le soir du
vote ou le lendemain du vote on n'avait
pas le vainqueur déterminé et que le
vainqueur de la nuit du du mardi au
mercredi n'était plus le vainqueur une
semaine plus tard et je veux juste un
véritable problème
j'ai dit 70% des électeurs américains
c'est des électeurs républicains qui
c'était qui qui pensent donc que Joe
Biden n'est pas légitime non non c'est
ce que je disais parce que la part prise
par le vote par correspondance en 2020
totalement inhabituel a créé des
résultats qui eux-mêmes étaient
inhabituels un peu légitime c'est ça
c'est ça que j'entends
de toute façon une semaine
avant on va penser que les républicains
ont gagné mais le panorama va changer au
fur et à mesure qu'il y a des
pouillements des bulletins de vote par
correspondante tous les médias y compris
Fox l'a dit il faut qu'on fasse
attention et c'est d'ailleurs Fox qui a
déclaré Biden président en disant qu'il
avait remporté l'Arizona et Fox est
évidemment un média qu'on peut
soupçonner
je vais vous lire une une un compte
rendu c'est une décision de la Cour
suprême du Wisconsin concernant les
élections de 2020 c'est pas c'est pas un
républicain qui parle concernant
l'élection je lis excusez-moi je le dis
je le dis est-ce que concernant
l'élection 2020 dans le Wisconsin le
nombre des votes comptabilisés alors
qu'il ne respectait pas la
réglementation électorale est plus
important que la marge de victoire de
Joe Biden néanmoins il n'y a pas de
preuve d'une faute massive en toute
vraisemblance Joe Biden a remporté plus
de votes légitime que Donald Trump nous
y sommes le nombre le nombre respectif
des règles et des procédures à soulever
des questions concernant l'équité du
processus et concernant les unité de
prod question qui n'aurait pas pu être
soulevé si les règles et procédures
avaient été respectées je suis désolé
mais tout est là c'est clair
le texte dit que Joe Biden l'emportait
même si il y a eu des irrégularités qui
dépassent les gardes des voix en sa
faveur mais en toute vraisemblance il a
gagné en toute vraisemblance les
élections ne devraient pas se décider en
toute vraisemblance on Arizona aussi des
individus armés ont été filmés ces
derniers jours montant la garde sur un
lieu de vote dans le but sans doute
d'intimider les électeurs un juge
fédéral a dit que c'était possible de
les laisser faire James Cohen au nom de
quoi on peut laisser faire politique du
juge certainement parce que c'était une
interprétation très très large on va
dire du premier amendement à la
Constitution mais mais il faudrait par
la même occasion signaler que dans ce
même état d'Arizona la personne qui
pourrait être élu le candidat
républicain poste secrétaire d'État pour
y être celui qui est chargé de gérer les
élections désormais et c'est un
républicain Maga pro Trump qui
ni les résultats qui dit que bon bref il
pouvait faire du
manipulation grave une des vrais
atteintes à la démocratie sont à
craindre on voit une radicalisation
d'une certaine France du parti
républicain
comment elle désigne les institutions
américaines vont pouvoir tenir encore
face à cette radicalisation
l'intimidation il faut se rappeler
historiquement qu'en 1981 un juge il
n'était pas nommé par Trump a pris un
décret interdisant aux républicains
d'entrer dans les bureaux de vote à
cause de leur historique de pression
intimidation manipulation ce décret est
resté en vigueur jusqu'en 2017
malheureusement il est tombé en 2017 et
là les républicains sont en train de
recruter tout un tas de gens qui sont
des magasins mais que RET again qui vont
les bureaux de vote et ISO comme
instruction de semer le chaos et de
trouver la moindre petite irrégularité
le type Amal signé la signer en verre au
lieu d'un bleu pour contester et on peut
prédire je peux vous dire qu'on n'aura
pas les résultats ni le soir même ni le
lendemain il va y avoir des dizaines de
contestations c'est si de contentieux
devant les tribunaux dans si bien que
les partis politiques sont en train de
mettre de l'argent de côté pour financer
toutes ses procès devant les tribunaux
voilà alors comment on peut sauver la
démocratie je ne sais pas et Gérald
Olivier qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
vous c'est ces hommes armés à proximité
de bureau de vote en Arizona à voir mais
à proximité de bureau de vote il y a pas
non plus à avoir des militants qui
viennent chez vous pour récupérer votre
bulletin et le remplir eux-mêmes et ça
c'est fait dans un certain nombre
d'États maintenant la réponse est dans
la question ce que vous citiez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que on parle
beaucoup de suppression du vote mais
vous le disiez la participation n'a
jamais été aussi élevée donc le vote de
qui est en train de supprimer si on
supprime et que la participation est la
plus élevée quand même un paradoxe
ensuite en ce qui concerne les règles du
droit de vote je rappelle qu'en France
quand on vote il faut une carte
d'électeur il faut se présenter avec une
carte d'identité dans la plupart des
États où il y a eu des réformes la
réforme a consisté à demander à ce que
lorsqu'on vient voter en personne on est
sur soi une pièce d'identité avec
peut-être même une photo et peut-être
même pas c'est pas du tout supprimer le
droit c'est au contraire c'est pas
discriminatoire c'est pas
discriminatoire du tout les Américains
qu'ils soient sont capables d'avoir une
pièce d'identité c'est pas du tout
discriminatoire mais justement aux
États-Unis d'autant qu'aux États-Unis la
plupart des pièges identité peuvent être
obtenus sans connaissance forcément à
présenter un certificat de naissance il
y a énormément de migrants clandestins
et on n'a pas besoin de seuls les
Américains ont le droit de vote pour
certaines minorités justement c'est
difficile de se procurer ses papiers
d'identité et ça ça a été fait justement
pour permettre à ces minorités de
pouvoir goûter c'est de s'accrocher au
pouvoir en jouant sur la marge et en
jouant sur des critères ne paraissent
pas discriminatoire que mais qui le sont
dans les faits en Floride ils sont
passés mettre dans cet argent aussi au
Texas qui le font oui c'est d'ailleurs
dans une opinion dissidente dans une
affaire où une fois de plus la Cour
suprême
jetée par terre les règles
anti-descrimination elle a dit les
législatures des états gouvernés par la
République après des règles qui en
apparence s'appliquent à tout le monde
mais qui dans les faits sont
discriminatoires vis-à-vis des minorités
et c'est ça c'est tout ça cela étant
c'est moi-même qui les dit la
participation est très bonne donc on ne
sait pas cela étant si c'est comme il y
a deux ans ou ça pourrait être en faveur
des démocrates mais aussi des
républicains il y a pas de voir aussi
que les électeurs les déminorités je
crois que c'était en Géorgie et je sais
plus c'était en 2018 ou en 2020 ils ont
fait la queue 8 heures pour aller voter
parce que les petits camarades
républicain avait fermé des tas de
bureau de vote juste dans les endroits
où il y avait des minorités pas de
chance pour moi il y a quelque chose de
plus profond qui est en train de se
passer c'est à dire que en 2008 lorsque
Obama a été élu vous avez eu un certain
nombre d'études qui sont sortis pour
vous dire que les démocrates allaient
démocratiquement démographiquement aller
avoir la majorité politique pour des
décennies à venir parce que les
minorités étaient en expansion
démographique parce qu'ils avaient le
vote qui leur était acquis parce que le
vote hispanique leur était acquis parce
qu'une majorité des femmes vote plutôt
démocrate que républicain et c'est pas
ce qui s'est produit ce qui a d'ailleurs
à surpris énormément de démocrates et ce
qu'on constate aujourd'hui et on verra
si ces élections le confirment ou pas
c'est qu'on a justement à l'intérieur au
moins de 2 groupes de minorités très
importants la minorité noire la minorité
à froid américaine et la minorité hymane
on a un basculement du vote voilà 90% de
noir votre démocrate ça c'est la règle
habituelle bah je peux vous garantir que
cette année ce sera pas le cas
rendez-vous on sera en dessous des 80 %
voire plus bas pour les Espagnols c'est
exactement la même chose on a un certain
nombre de gens qui quittent le Parti
démocrate et puis rappelons-le dans la
campagne il y a quand même eu quelque
chose que vous n'avez pas évoqué mais il
y a eu le revirement de Madame
tulsigabarbe madame tussigabarde est une
démocrate elle était candidate à la
nomination
elle a fait un discours pour expliquer
pourquoi elle renonçait à appartenir aux
parties démocrate et moi je recommande à
tout le monde de regarder la vidéo parce
que son disque il faut comprendre
l'anglais mais son discours est une
formidable un form véritable résumé de
tous les problèmes de l'administration
et du parti démocrates opportuniste
parce qu'elle se rapproche des
républicains et la discussion
si comme le prédisent les sondages les
républicains contrôlent les deux
chambres la semaine prochaine ça veut
dire quoi pour Joe Biden il ne pourra
plus gouverner jusqu'à la fin de son
mandat oui déjà et ça veut dire quoi
aussi pour Donald Trump
Donald Trump qui est en embuscade pour
il est temps d'embuscade on ne sait pas
si Elon Musk va lui rendre son accès à
Twitter ce qui serait aussi intéressant
il a dit qu'il se passerait rien avant
le 4 novembre il y aura une commission
etc
exactement la minute où il a racheté
Twitter on a multiplié par 10 les propos
de haine de violence et de menaces donc
le climat va être terrible le problème
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de républicains
qui ont eu peur de Trump et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils ont menti c'est
la raison pour laquelle ils n'ont pas
dénoncé le mensonge sur l'élection et
non pas dénoncé la violence du 6 janvier
mais là il commence à se rendre compte
que Trump n'est pas un atout pour eux
déjà là ils essaient de pas la voir dans
certains états parce que c'est trop
risqué et ils n'ont pas très envie qu'il
soit candidats en 2024 un à cause de
tous ces comportements erratiques et
deux parce que toute façon il pourrait
pas faire un autre mandat et tant qu'à
faire les républicains se disent si on
réussit à capturer la Maison Blanche
autant que ce soit pour 8 ans donc les
choses aussi Donald Trump tout comme Joe
Biden
puisqu'il en a déjà fait donc alors il y
a tous ces éléments ça va être
extrêmement mouvant enfin c'est
difficile de prédire l'avenir je veux
dire personnellement si déjà les
démocrates pouvaient conserver le Sénat
ce serait bien pour le rôle
international des États-Unis et ce
serait bien pour les confirmations de
juge fédéraux et notamment dans le cadre
de la guerre en Ukraine parce que vous
avez entendu les les républicains qui
commencent à dire voilà c'est fini le
checkbook le carnet de check pour
l'Ukraine et ça ça pourrait avoir des
conséquences au-delà bien sûr que c'est
inquiétant c'est que ceux qui vont
remporter les élections du côté
républicain un bon tiers va être des
magas des protrom c'est-à-dire
isolationniste droite douanes
anti-financé l'Ukraine anti-rôles des
États-Unis au plan international
anti-otant c'est-à-dire le programme si
on peut parler de programme de Monsieur
Trump James Cohen un dernier mot et
ensuite Gérald Olivier ce qu'on a plus
beaucoup de temps il nous reste 3
minutes un dernier mot ben écoutez les
dés ne sont pas jetés rendez-vous encore
une fois le 9 novembre pour voir quels
sont les résultats et les je pense que
on a déjà évoqué les risques qui sont
gros à mon avis d'une perte d'une grande
mesure de la démocratie qui nous reste
c'est pour ça que nous sommes dans cette
bataille pour la défendre et le bilan du
parti Républic
démocrates on a peu évoqué et ces deux
dernières années suivant une une
pandémie ils n'ont pas été facile mais
il y a quand même un bilan à défendre
est-ce que les démocrates est-ce que
nous l'avons suffisamment défendu tout
le long de ces campagnes on verra mardi
prochain mais en tout cas voilà l'enjeu
Gérald Olivier si les républicains
l'emporte à la fois la chambre et au
Sénat c'est sûr que pour Joe Biden c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de faire passer
son agenda ensuite ce sera la
républicains qui contrôleront justement
le planning parce qu'ils sont ils auront
les commissions ils auront les
présidents des commissions maintenant en
politique et dans le journalisme vous
savez très bien au lendemain des meeters
on parlera de la présidentielle donc on
se dirige à mon avis vers des primaires
à la fois pour les démocrates et pour
les républicains parce que les candidats
sont pas encore acquis merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois merci Anne
désigne merci Gérald Olivier merci James
Cohen d'avoir été avec nous en plateau
c'était notre débat resté avec nous
l'information continue sur France 24